"Кривавий пат". Так описують західні військові експерти воєнну ситуацію в Україні
через три з половиною тижні після початку розв'язаної Росією війни.
Через завзятий опір українців російський наступ сповільнився,
і сторони дедалі більше переходять до позиційних боїв.
Російська тактика мене поки що не переконала.
Загальновійськовий бій до ладу не опанований, що може бути обумовлено слабкістю піхоти батальйонно-тактичних груп.
Через це головну ставку доводиться робити на артилерію та установки залпового вогню.
А це озброєння, які в умовах міста мають руйнівну дію.
Ця зброя вражає великі площі. Я не стверджую, що удари по цивільних об'єктах здійснюються навмисне,
але російське керівництво цілком свідоме того, що цього не уникнути -
тому що площа ураження настільки велика, що під вогонь потрапляють цивільні цілі.
І вони на це йдуть свідомо.
На урядовій пресконференції у Берліні цього тижня представник міністерства оборони Німеччини прокоментував ситуацію так.
Зрозуміло, що ми вкрай уважно стежимо за тим, що відбувається в Україні.
Ми уважно спостерігаємо за діями російської сторони.
Можна стверджувати, що російська сторона була здивована неймовірним і подиву гідним духом опору українців та українок.
За нашими оцінками, російська сторона з цим узагалі не рахувалася.
Проте від конкретніших оцінок тактики ведення бойових дій представник уряду відмовився.
Значні жертви серед мирного населення засуджують і в Бундестазі.
Проте у парламентському комітеті з питань оборони вважають, що Німеччина наразі робить усе, що може.
На мою думку, Німеччина робить все, щоб підтримати Україну.
Ми не втручаємося у війну безпосередньо - ми цього не хочемо.
Ми не хочемо воювати з Росією.
Але ми підтримуємо Україну зброєю - настільки, наскільки можливо.
Ось тільки у нас її не так багато!
Ми перевірили арсенали Бундесверу та відправляємо те, що є - шоломи та комплекси протиповітряної оборони.
Подальші позиції перевіряються.
Ми також відправляли паливо та боєприпаси.
Тобто те, що маємо, те й відправляємо. І ми дуже уважно стежимо за ситуацією.
Німецькі експерти впевнені, що найгірше ще попереду і що удари по цивільним цілям посилюватимуться.
Очевидно, що російські війська переходять до того, щоб атакувати міста
та використовувати для цього артилерію, ракети та крилаті ракети.
І тим самим збільшити втрати української сторони та посилити тиск на Україну.
Прагнення досягти військового успіху дедалі посилюватиметься,
і тому робитиметься ставка на озброєння, що вражають велику площу.
Навіть більшою мірою, ніж на повітряні сили.
А щодо військової авіації, по-перше, мене здивувало те, що українські військово-повітряні сили ще існують
і, по-друге, що Росія досі не завоювала повний контроль у повітрі.
А також що російська сторона змушена використовувати ракети великої дальності,
запускаючи їх з російського чи білоруського повітряного простору,
що не потребує присутності у повітряному просторі України.
Однією з цілей російського наступу було захоплення серця України - Києва.
Колишній командувач військами США в Європі Бен Ходжес сумнівається, що армія РФ на це взагалі здатна.
Я думаю, що росіянам не вдасться оточити Київ, а тим більше захопити його.
Дивіться, скільки часу вони намагаються захопити Маріуполь.
Для росіян, це мало би бути найпростіше місто для захоплення,
враховуючи близькість їхнього військово флоту та сил у Криму та на Донбасі,
але вони досі не змогли це зробити.
Я не вірю, що них є можливість фактично оточити Київ.
Я був там п’ять тижнів тому. Я був там кілька разів.
Це дуже, дуже велике місто на березі однієї з найбільших річок Європи, дуже складний міський рельєф.
У росіян немає потужностей, щоб оточити його.
Робити прогнози щодо можливих термінів та подальшого ходу бойових дій експерти відмовляються -
надто непередбачено розвивається ситуація в Україні.